وحده خاصه من قوات الدرك الايطالي
الكربانياري القات القبض على هذا الستيني
نحيل البنيان في مدينه باليرمو بجزيره
صقليه ناقل المافيا الاشهر
زعيم عصابه كوسان
دينارو الملقب بديابوليك او الشيطاني
اختبا من العداله منذ 30 عاما بعد ارتكابه
سلسله من الجرائم التي اوصلته لتصدر لائحه
اكثر المطلوبين للعداله الايطاليه وضمن
اكثر عشره مجرمين خطوره في العالم
رئيسه الوزراء جورج جميل انتقلت شخصيا
لجزيره صقليه لتشكر مسؤولي القضاء والشرطه
على هذا الانجاز الذي وصفته بانتصار
للدوله
نسينا دينارو ابتدا مسيرته الاجراميه في
مطلع الثمانينات من القرن الماضي كاتل
ماجور بسيط الى عام
1993 حيث شارك في التخطيط وتنفيذ سلسله من
التفجيرات التي استهدفت قضاه وسياسيين
ايطاليين واودت بحياه العشرات
وكان الهدف منها هو ارهاب الحكومه
الايطاليه لتطلق سراحه زعيم المافيا ان
ذاك سلفادور ريرينا وعددا من معاونه فشلت
حمله التفجيرات في ارغام الحكومه
الايطاليه على اطلاق سراح رجال المافيا
المسجونين فاختفى مسينا دينارو
لثلاثه عقود الى ان القي عليه القبض في
مستشفى في صقليه